[Music]
robin is in cleveland ohio hey robin how
are you
i'm doing all right how are you today
better than i deserve what's up
i have a question my husband and i are
finishing up
baby step three we have about five
months in savings
and we're debating on whether we should
refinance our home
um we have a hundred thousand dollars on
our house and we have around sixty
thousand dollars
on a second mortgage when we were doing
dave ramsey-ish
and my husband built a barn that he uses
as like a side business
but so we were wondering if we should
refinance and can combine the barn and
the house on the same
payment plan yeah what's the interest
rate on your first mortgage
our interest rate on the first mortgage
is like a 3.7
and on the barn it's like a 6.2 yeah
and you're going to stay in the home a
while oh yeah i don't
we don't plan on ever leaving definitely
definitely refinance it while you're at
it put it on 15 year
you can get cheaper on the barn and
cheaper on the house and so you've got
160 thousand
half 60 000 which you're gonna save
three and some change
and you're probably gonna save about
three quarters of a percent on the
hundred thousand on the first
and my husband's concern he says he
feels like he's starting over i don't
know
how to help him through that i don't
feel like it's starting over
because we've already been paying on the
house for 10 years yeah there's a
some people don't um he's one of them
they have the idea that you pay all the
interest up front
and that he has to start overpaying all
the interest and that's because when you
look at an
amateurization schedule when you look at
your payment schedule and how much of it
is going to interest out of the very
first payment it's almost
all interest and that makes you think
you're pre-paying interest up front
sometimes you're not he's not starting
over
so the way the interest is calculated on
a traditional
conventional mortgage is it's based on
the outstanding balance
that month and so your very first
payment you have the largest
outstanding balance you will ever have
and so you have the more so a higher
percentage you know 99 of that first
payment goes to interest right
you've seen that you've seen that math
schedule right yeah oh yeah okay
so what let's just pretend uh let's
pretend it was three percent
which would be .25 a month
a quarter of a percent a month would be
three percent a year
okay so whatever's outstanding that
month
a quarter of a percent is going to be
owed on it
if you're if your interest rate's three
percent and so he's not starting over
he's got sixty thousand dollars and a
quarter of a percent
of that will go to a quarter of a
percent
will be his portion of the payment and
the rest of it will be principal which
will be a tiny tiny bit
but you're not starting over you do
mortgages are not
front loaded with interest okay
that's what his he he misunderstood that
yeah that's what he's getting hung up on
he doesn't want to start over they're
not free he's not starting over he's
doing well
he's not starting over he's starting
exactly the same place he is but with a
lower interest rate
because this month he's going to get
charged 1 12 of
6 and some change which is a half a
percent on the 60
000 this month he's gonna get charged
one twelfth of three point seven percent
on the hundred thousand
and the rest of it is going to go to
principal
it's simple interest calculation the
outstanding balance times the interest
rate
is the amount of interest charged to
that month there is not
a front load on a mortgage it's
only charged for what you have
outstanding so you're not starting over
do a 15-year fixed
and refinances puppy you need to do it